Michael Wilbon from pardon the
interruption joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show joining all of us how you
doing Michael um got pretty good rich
how are you how was that moment huh
Jordan talking about Kobe in the past
yeah oh my god yeah you know some of
that a lot of that happened when Michael
was here in Washington in his what three
years one of the new executive to as a
player and executive and you know I'm
not gonna sit here and say I didn't know
about it I did know about it in terms of
just Kobe's the phone calls and it was
more phone calling than text back then
we're talking about the turn of the
century and it was funny back then to
know a little bit about it I know about
their absolute you know the nature of
every conversation but yeah I knew that
Kobe held Michael and that kind of
regard and I've shared this story I'll
Sharon see it has a different context
now sure just as someone who covered you
know so much of Michaels career Kobe
knew that about me and my career and I
was one of those people who was never
gonna say that Kobe was better than
Michael Jordan or as good as I was just
was never gonna say that because I
didn't believe it even though I think
Kobe is the I practically is the second
best person to play our position in
history the game and and Kobe knew I
felt that way and it was a source of
just such good natured ribbing and so
after some games that I would attend
covering for The Washington Post where
Kobe might have had you know forty five
he might have scored on Vince Carter a
midol Tracy McGrady or you know some
great player outside of the locker room
as you know where media members are
waiting sort of in perhaps in line to go
in the locker room after after the game
Kobe would come over I get an elbow in
the ribs if I wasn't looking or elbow or
a punch and he would say lean over to me
when no one else could hear it and he
would say how would you boy have done
tonight when you break out in 45 tonight
could you boy I've done that to Tracy
McGrady tonight or Allen Iverson it was
just it was so good-natured and he'd
have a smile on his face and start
laughing and I've I
even said to him at one point will you
let me tell people about this can I
write about this he's like no no no
people think this wrong way Rio that and
so I never talked about it until in
three weeks ago and it was it was that
was perfect because I would say to him
I'm gonna I'm gonna call and tell me
what you just said because I'm gonna
call the wind call from locker room I'll
tell him and you know it was I'm coming
to get you old man and it was great
because Kobe he just he revered Michael
on every level if anybody thinks
anything other than that about these
stories or what Michael said yesterday
you know Kobe would want a Michael to
say he was here it was a Ted and he was
a nuisance he was getting under his skin
but he like a big like the big brother
Michael described exactly like that
and so yeah I mean I was privy to some
of it just based on my relationship with
Michael and Kobe knowing it but it was
it was so it was so much fun I never
teased back that was not my place right
I just said okay nope I don't know if he
could have gotten 45 I don't doubt it I
might have said one time he's gotten 55
tonight instead of 45 way but I mean
that you know it was just a yeah I got a
little glimpse it that's all it was a
little glimpse into the relationship
that they had and it was uh unlike I I
think I can say this in a you know if
I'm wrong Michael to hear about it he'll
tell me I think it was unlike any
relationship he ever had with another
player I think I'm saying well I mean
how long did it take to get there
because I imagine you know when an
eighteen-year-old comes in the league
and Jerry West is singing his praises
and put him out here in the the Tiffany
organization of the Lakers and seeing
whatever was going on with the Lakers
and then Shaq showing up I wonder what
the origins you remember the origins
Michael okay the origin the origins of
the Jordan Kobe relationship how it all
started oh I think it was just
Koby so I'm talking about 1999-2000 I'm
talking about that period yeah we did
he's only about his fourth year so I
don't know that it took all that long
we're not talking about 2000 you know
after championships talking about pre no
issues I thought you were talking about
later you guys doing this stuff too you
know what you know what it all happened
at the same time rich because the Lakers
won in 2000 and 2001 and - correct right
so it's about the same time and it was
developing but I'm sure some of it
happened before because I mean Michael
had to eat played only a couple of times
in his last year no he didn't he only
came when he came back I guess the only
played against Kobe when he came back
with the Wizards but whatever was it was
but some of that was pre championship
and look Michael loved beating those
that whole posse young people he loved
it now he did not try he did not feel
like they're young and brash and I'm
tired of he didn't he just thought
they're young and they're great and I
want to hold them off and we had many
conversations about this he did not
begrudge Allen Iverson he did not
begrudge Tracy McGrady he did not
begrudge cope he didn't and there were
times where I know if I said something
if I wrote something at the time there
was he thought was hyper critical I
would get a phone call he said hey hey
you stop you got to lay off these kids
and so he was protective of them I know
it sounds you know contradictory he was
protective of them rich on one hand in
terms of just give them time to incubate
why wanting to just take them apart on
the court that's who people should note
that to Michael is but now they should
know that from watching them and with
Kobe but but the relationship I'm gonna
say and this is my assessment I'm never
asking this I'm gonna say the
relationship with Kobe was very
different than the relationship even
with with any of the other young guns
and he he he wasn't a mentor and say the
same way magic was but he had his own
way of doing it and and and the
relationship with Kobe was different
Michael Wilbon here on the Rich Eisen
show hey man Congrats on getting into
the your call to the Hall the Naismith
Basketball
fain say I am honored and humbled and
you know a little overwhelmed by it and
I you know and to have that honor to
share that this year Curt Goudy award
with with my brain and in a special
category created with my dear friend
Charles Ernie Kenny and Shaq but you
know Charles is you know one of my dear
friends now for more than I don't know
20 to 20 plus years it that that's it's
just I'm humbled by and I'm overwhelmed
by it and obviously Kobe's gonna go in
this fall too so I can't even I can't
even wrap my head around I can't wrap my
head around any of this stuff Michael no
no you know I don't look to me in any
Hall of Fame and I know everybody didn't
they have media wing when the hard thing
is for players and coaches and mostly
players and so I don't I mean I try I
whenever I speak of it I'm trying to I'm
careful to make sure that you know
people who understand I've had players
crawling congratulate me or during
all-star weekend young players even
loyal and beat gave me a big hug and
saying congratulations get all seven I
said I am humbled by it and I am but you
know I know when Charles and magic did
say that it's it's you know the Hall of
Fame is for players and I'm glad that
there is this observation at the hall
for media people and so many people on
that that Kurt Goudy list of my mentors
and my dear friends and I'm overjoyed to
be joining them so it's it's all of them
and in giving you that you just to know
the notion of Kobe this year is just
like okay I can't even maybe because I
don't I just don't want to think about
well I know that I got I got to the
point Ridge where it's just like okay
I'm gonna think about this privately I
don't know that I want to talk about it
much more right now you sometimes you
just need some reflection and but
yesterday I thought well I was wrong
because I think I don't know who said it
on the record I don't know if those
magic somebody said we people needed
this and I thought you know what yeah
yep people did need it Michael Michael
Wilbon here on the Rich Eisen show right
before I let you go I want you to put
you in the
of bears fan here Ryan pace said today
general manager the Bears they're gonna
make a decision on Travis Keys 50 or
option in May what do you think they
should do Michael well it depends it
depends rich on the options I mean what
are the options is it Marcus Mariota am
I getting a real upgrade there what just
like if I knew like he's got to know
what the options are when he says
they're gonna make it in May you better
spend the next two and a half months
figuring out what his options are I'm
not as down on true Biscay as a lot of
people are not and I was originally down
on a pick because they traded so many
picks they changed so much to get him on
draft day well they didn't have to they
could have just said the Bears are like
mr. Biscay there wasn't a posse of teams
trying to get at him so Ryan pay screwed
that up let's let's be let's be fair
general managers you know he may be off
and don't take the hits for their own
decision and they come back and say we
gotta make a decision on this guy well
you should have made the right decision
in the first place and drafted Patrick
my homes or deshaun Watson now having
said that I'm not a balancer 50 I think
he needs to be coached by somebody who
was permitted to coaching him huh that's
the coaching here that's the two years
ago coach of the year you're talking
about Michael what do you mean I get you
the NBA where'd I get the coach of
nothing but but I don't I've had people
tell me who were in positions no I mean
no he spent all this he spent you know
play that time dream and he was still
back in Kansas City a coach of mahomes
well if you want to stay if you want of
course Ron should've stayed there you
got this guy yes he didn't draft and
they drafted him before Negi got there
coach him how do we go some games where
the guy doesn't run at all use his legs
at all there's so many inconsistencies I
don't want to get into it there's
another I'm not a offseason fanatic and
I'm not gonna say it until you I watch
team but I talk to players and former
players and I've talked to players from
Kansas City
and their whole deal is he doesn't want
to coach him oh my god really and then
that those whispers rich were there in
Chicago and you just say okay this is
just talk it's just you know I mean look
we Negi can coach but I'm not saying he
can't coach but he's got to want to
commit to this guy and if he doesn't
want to do that and pace knows that then
get rid then go ahead and then don't
sign them but do I believe the Mitsui
Biscay can be a playoff quarterback in
the NFL yes if coached up and you know I
don't I think coaching is woefully
inadequate today relative to I go
through this I go through the 1985
standings I've done this with my
producers at PTI and I've just I've just
gone through the coaches and
coordinators and it's like today I mean
it's like I would throw over like most
of the coaches today for the guys who
are coaching it in and you can say well
you know that now no we knew that then
we know a lot about that vent because
you still had Shula's and you had
Landry's and you had Hall of Fame guys
and the secondary guys even one super
balls or got damn close and so I I think
he can play at a playoff level the Bears
got to a Super Bowl with rex grossman
rich I feel with the defense and special
teams that they usually have including
this past season you know and I know how
it undermines great different people say
well the Bears defense didn't play up to
the level every day no cuz they were
they were angry half the time I've
learned this from knowing the likes of
mr. Dick Butkus when people walk off the
field defensively for the Bears Hall of
Famers it would walk off the field and
Brian Urlacher too and it would save the
offensive players can you just hold him
until we get back and this is the
history of that franchise right so now
you're asking me to dump a quarterback
who with twelve and four back it back it
went well before too didn't he if Negi
went well before didn't didn't true
Biscay do that well part of the reason
why him others but it depends on whether
that guy wants to coach him honestly
commit to him and coach him yeah the
reason why he won coach the is he went
12 and forward drew Biscay michael
that's right you know that he was it
I'm I'm can tell I'm conflicted and I'm
not as down on true Biscay as a whole a
lot of people I think he can win in the
NFL Michael thanks for the call
really appreciate it again Congrats hear
from you and talking with you man I
appreciate that
right back at you that's Michael Wilbon
at real Mike will bond on Twitter follow
him with the millions for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 under red TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app